make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin all right what's going on
guys this is rob we are picking back up
again
with the joker war and this is oh my god
harley quinn's amazing in this story
okay
so so we initially pick up here with
joker
making a move what he ends up getting is
like one of these great big huge stretch
limousines looks like a hummer stretch
limousine and kind of makes this thing
worse
it's designed to be ludicrous looking
right it's just spray-painted with
smiley faces and hahas and all that kind
of stuff
but he ends up making his way towards
ace chemical and as he's doing this
it looks as though he's basically
talking to the driver and he asked the
driver he says what's your name
the guy says my name's abe and he's like
are you a life or a meaning has he
always grown up in gotham city or is he
is he a transplant and gabe's or abe's
response is well i've lived here my
entire life and that's when joker kind
of asked the question like isn't it nice
to see
like the city basically waking up right
to see that the city's been pretending
to be something that it's not and that
has finally come to grips with what it
really is
this is interesting here's the thing i
don't want to get super political on
this but this is cool right and i'm not
going to make you know comparisons to
the real world outside of saying
there's some truth to what the joker
says here in the sense
that there's for us as people there is a
kind of desire to just
let that darker side be free like we
keep ourselves contained we keep
ourselves organized we keep ourselves
structured
we abide by this kind of social contract
and any organized society
you have laws that say like it's illegal
to steal and we don't really follow
those laws because we believe that
they're genuinely the right thing to do
right i mean
i would challenge anybody out there like
a parent or somebody like that then if
they're kids starving you do what you
need to do right like you steal from who
you need to steal in order to make sure
your kid eats like that's something that
i firmly believe
but as people there's a kind of rule
that we follow
not necessarily because of the fact that
we believe it's for the greater good but
because if that rule exists
then it means there's recourse if it
happens to us right so we have laws that
say it's illegal to steal not because we
genuinely believe stealing's wrong but
because if somebody steals from us then
it means that we have recourse for it
and depending on where you live
your geographic location that recourse
can change from one place to the next
right somebody breaks into your house
if you live in like colorado or texas or
someplace like that you have stand your
ground laws so you can tell them to
leave they don't you can shoot them on
site i mean that just just that kind of
thing other states you can't really do
that so much but the idea is that there
is a kind of natural nature to
lawlessness that exists between people
because
what the joker's giving us here and
while it's not necessarily all of gotham
itself one thing to understand is that
these people who are running around as
clowns and wearing masks they're not
some kind of
individuals who are possessed by some
kind of evil out there they're just
people and what they've been told is
the city is yours you can do whatever
you want with it and when given that
choice to do whatever it is that they
want they start tearing it up they start
ripping it to pieces
right and this kind of follows the
thomas hobbs approach of philosophy
right
in a state of nature where there is no
ordered government whatsoever people
will devolve into a perpetual and
permanent war of all against all
over resources that's kind of what this
is right to a degree and so it's one of
these things where the joker kind of
looks and says like batman never really
saw gotham for what it was right batman
believed that he could change that that
he believed that he could take this city
from a place where you could be walking
down the street and get mugged by a cop
or
criminal and the only difference between
the two was was the uniforms they wore
and try to turn it into a place where
everybody was safe but what batman
always failed to realize is the reason
why gotham is the worst place in all of
the world and in the world for the most
part is because
it's just how people naturally are here
it's such an interesting philosophy to
have
because there's truth to that people
don't move to bad places
so they can be good guys right people go
to bad places they can be bad guys right
they can do bad things do things they're
not supposed to do
that's the idea behind why those things
exist in the first place so it's
interesting because
the you know the joker looks at this and
says batman believes that gotham city is
his city he believes that like it's the
city that he's there to protect but all
he's doing is protecting it from me and
people like me so if batman is there to
protect the city from people like me
then is it batman city or is it my city
and that's the reality is it's
joker city that's really what it is
right it's so it's it's really kind of
awesome because
you get to this point where he ends up
of course getting a call from punchline
and in punchline you know basically you
know
where the question is like you know
what's that noise he's like oh i don't
know he's just killing the driver
basically and so with that happening she
basically tells the joker that you know
her encounter with with harley quinn
didn't work harley quinn's not dead
batman's back and the concern is that
batman's gonna start going on a war path
but joker's not really worried about it
and while he's going through there and
basically executing every single one of
his guys inside ace chemical to kind of
clear the way
and and remove all this you know all
this this resistance for batman he
really kind of says like i'm not worried
about him right like i know batman
better than he probably knows himself
i can predict him i know where he's
going to go and he's going to come here
so here's what i want right i want that
monarch theater to be full of
to be full of capacity so tell the
clowns everybody out there
that he'll pay a thousand dollars for
every dead body they bring to him and if
they bring the bat it'll be a million
dollars he's literally putting out a
bounty on just
average citizens out there so cut to
batman and what batman's done here is
basically reassemble the entirety of the
bat family which have kind of
been off doing their own thing and
batman's really been trying to solve
this problem on his own but the reality
of this is that this is too big of a
problem for him to solve by himself more
so than that batman
you know he also kind of seems to
realize the failing right the the fault
in the stars and so far as he looks at
what's been happening here and basically
saying that he's been too cut off right
now
this is kind of the issue the little bit
of an issue that i have with this is
we've seen this before
right batman's like in some crazy
situation and it's like oh man guys i'm
sorry i never really appreciated you for
how awesome you were well things are
gonna change now right we saw that after
in the aftermath of like death of the
family we saw that during tom king's
batman and we're seeing it here it's
okay but to happen to have it happen
like you know run after run after run
like three times in a row
it does kind of get it you know get a
little old because you largely assume
this is all still one continuity in
batman comics so it's like okay like is
it just like with each instance this
happened batman realizes he needs him
like a little bit more
and then you know if we if we've done it
three times so far that's like you know
the first time he realized he needed
them 33
more than he did before and now it's
like 66 more during tom king's batman
now he's at like 99
you know so just a little bit more and
he'll realize exactly how much he needs
them like i don't i don't know
i don't really know but the the
important thing here is he basically
says
the entire city of gotham is a complete
and total chaos that the whole place is
being laid to waste and it only gets
worse from here
it's only going to get worse that what
you have is an assault by batman or at
least by the bat family that's happening
on multiple fronts right you've got
batwoman and the gotham city police
department that are leading an assault
on on
on wayne enterprises the idea is to
basically get all that money back right
you know lucious fox has essentially
been rescued here you know so the idea
is to kind of regain control of wayne
enterprises
but on top of all that they have to find
a way to stop the violence and they have
to find a way to stop the joker and
that's why this is kind of a
multi-faceted strike that the bat family
is expected to be strategically placed
in different locations around gotham the
most conducive to their various
abilities in order to
you know bring an end to all the crime
that's going on out there at the same
time batman's going to go directly after
the joker and that's when some of the
bat families step
in red hood steps in batgirl steps in
and even like harley quinn steps in
right and harley quinn's just like no
that's not gonna happen this is not
gonna be a thing where like you take out
joker no like this
this story has to end now because you're
gonna do what you've always done which
is grab the joker throw him in prison
and then he'll get out and do this all
over again
now that argument is gonna become a
little more prevalent here in a little
while the reason why it gets cut short
is because one of the clown spots about
family fires a rocket
batman throws a batarang and of course
takes the rocket out and then you've got
spoiler you got orphan who show up there
and they basically end up taking out you
know the
you know taking out this clown but more
are on the way and so while the rest of
the bat family basically disperses
and goes about their their appointed
tasks that batman predicts uh presents
dick grayson
with his nightwing costume now the
reason why this matters is because
dc had the well i wouldn't say genius
idea they they had the idea
uh to basically have uh you know dick
grayson take a take a shot to the head
and then basically lose his memories of
who he was and then he started calling
himself rick grayson and that happened
in the nightwing comics
i've heard super mixed things about it
right like i've heard it's pretty
polarizing either people love it or
people
hate it uh there really is no in between
there really don't seem to be a lot of
people who were like it was okay
you know like the stories were a little
hit and miss and depending on what story
you're reading i never really heard that
but this is basically dc like bringing
dick grayson back to the person that he
was right he already regained his
memories he already knows who he is and
it's just kind of a formality here right
like regaining the nightwing costume and
going back to being nightwing again a
lot of this really seems to be because
of the fact that rick grayson wasn't
really received all that well
and i imagine dc didn't really expect to
keep it all that long right and so of
course we also had catwoman who led
penguin and riddler out of their hideout
you know with promises of of
wealth you know with billions of dollars
exactly what they intend to do we're not
a 100 sure
it seems to me that they're basically
going and and kind of following batwoman
and the gotham city police department
into wayne enterprises for the purpose
of doing what they probably won't be
able to do on their own but then of
course you pick up with batman
showing up at ace chemicals and as soon
as he gets here he gets a gunshot fired
at his foot by harley quinn and the
reason why harley's here
is because she doesn't trust batman and
there's really no reason for her too
in her mind she says like the story has
to end here and and at the end of the
day batman's like i cannot kill the
joker and harley's like that's your
problem
that's your issue here is how many times
has the joker done this
how many times has the joker laid siege
to the city of gotham how many times has
the joker taken everything that you
stand for
and turned it upside down how many
members of your family has the joker
almost killed how many people has a
joker successfully killed and that's the
argument she kind of presents here and
it's a genius argument right like the
problem with batman in the eyes of
harley quinn
is gotham city is the most violent city
in the world and the joker is the most
violent criminal in the world and so if
the joker is as violent and psychotic as
he is and every time the batman catches
joker and puts him back into arkham
asylum and the joker escapes and
something like this happens
how long is this gonna go on for how
long is this dance gonna be played
something has to change whenever i
create that argument a lot of people
kind of introduce the straw man argument
and then point to like other comic book
characters and say well you know why
don't spider-man and you know
why does spider-man kill his villains
right why doesn't like thor kill his
villains or the incredible hulk or
somebody like that i guess they could
but there is merit to making the
argument and saying that when it comes
to batman he's got the most violent
criminals in all of comic books
the most violent criminals in all of
comic books it kind of makes sense that
batman would kill his villains if for no
other reason than to kill a joker and at
least get him
off the table and so i think there's an
actual meritable argument to be made in
saying
batman should kill his villains right
that's kind of the craziness behind it
all and that's harley quinn's whole
stance so she basically says here's
what's gonna happen
if you go in there and if the joker
kills you i'm gonna kill him i'm gonna
put a bullet in his head and we're gonna
end it and batman's response is
no you can't do that then and harley's
responses then kill me right now if
that's really what you believe if you
really believe that the joker should
continue on doing what he's doing you
know joker's going to do this again and
so what you know is he's going to kill
innocent people which means you're okay
with the joker killing innocent people
right if you weren't you would kill him
in order to keep innocent people from
dying but you could but you keep him
alive and you know what he's gonna do
so either you can kill me now or you can
accept
that i'm going to do what needs to be
done and in this moment i would say
harley quinn
is more of a more of a of a superhero
than batman is i know superheroes
aren't people who kill criminals but
superheroes are people who protect to
protect innocent people and if
protecting an innocent person means
taking out a taking out a criminal sorry
about your luck right you can call me an
anti-hero all you want to that's just
the way that it goes right that's just
the way that it is
don't do criminal things don't lay waste
to an entire city and kill
thousands of people if you don't want to
die right like that's just kind of the
way it is
i mean after all i'm not talking about
killing people who who shoplift
so uh the idea here is that once batman
gets into ace chemicals he's immediately
met by
what he believes to be the joker right
he calls him out right off the bat says
joker is over right like right now we're
attacking wayne enterprises we're taking
down all your clowns everybody's gone
right like every like you're gonna lose
this whole thing but where batman
expects the joker to be the one that
meets him instead it's not the joker
what the joker has done is he went to
wayne manor and he went to the graveyard
in wayne manor and he
dug up alfred and then he infected
alfred and reanimated alfred as one of
his like zombie type guys and
literally you know batman's initial
response is oh my god like there's no
way this is real and that's when the
joker appears behind batman wearing his
own batman costume
right like literally a bat suit the
joker's got the joker gets a bat suit he
just says
see bruce i promised you're not ready
for all of this and that's true
bruce wayne was not ready for the
full-on madness of the joker with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comments explained make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
rob core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you